l'été les porter ça crie ça va le faire
ensemble
on savait non mais vous est ce que vous
pouvez faire ou pas moi je peux faire
disparaître is a regardé je vais moi je
vais téléporter garder votre ça et là et
bien regarder et ça et là bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous êtes vous êtes un des plus
grands bâtisseurs avec antoine mois par
la taille
non mais je vais vous montrer j'ai pris
quelques cours de match et parce que je
suis fasciné par la magie et je vous
faire un tour de magie ce soir je vais
choisir quelqu'un dans le public et je
vais la télé portée oui au hasard
complètement je vais prendre la première
personne qui me tombe sous la main à
kiki qui envient voilà ici dans le
public qui vous voulez on peut pas vous
vous venez venez venez je vais
téléporter cette version est bien
d'assurer une expérience unique au monde
vous saviez pas que j'avais des talents
de magicien et ben là je peux vous dire
vous allez avoir le cul concassées je
vous le dis vous ne risquez rien
d'accord géomètre dans cette cabine et
j'ai vous téléporter les jeunes nom de
dieu s'est tu quand même le seul
magicien qui les tâches d'offres au
niveau des trucs glover jeté pour un
autre tour face au ghana sont cloutées
[Rires]
j'avais vu la jeune fille cliquez là bas
dans la cabine et bien cette jeune fille
j'ai réussi à la jerry porter regarder
la cabine alors pas bouger pour aller
voir derrière toi n'est pas bien de toi
y'a pas que le public ne l'avait pas vu
passer le contrat est bien cette
personne est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baisser la garde et bien c'est de faire
ça je vois là regardez bien cette
personne je lui retourner là bas et je
réserve faire face et regarder non mais
c'est grillé il est revenu à corbeil
s'est mis à tourner
on se révolte vous êtes un des salons je
suis un homme à aller plus d'intérêt les
plus bas
il vient donner la cabine ouvrez logis
mais l'été les porter ça fait le christ
est venu de faire ensemble ces ambiances
arrêt non mais vous est ce que vous
pouvez faire ou pas moi je peux faire
disparaître et ça regarde et je vais moi
je vais téléporter garder votre hills à
regarder leur antre mais simple tu
deviens haute degrés regardez bien et ça
sort est là et bien regardez ici et là
bas
[Applaudissements]
et selon l'humeur
ou est-ce que vous avez un pourra nous
faire moi avec plaisir cyril alors
explosé on n'est pas complice tu le jura
non je vous jure bamako témoin avait la
cote il appartient aux quais sur la
première page de ce carnet il ya le nom
d'une carte iata carte la carte rethel
tu vas penser tu veux qu'on n'est pas
complice foule sur d'accord si tu mens
tu aurais aimé des gens il faut pas
confiance en moi tu peux pas prendre
quelqu'un d'autre avec caméra on attaque
ce que tu veux celui en qui on papa jean
michel mr forcément pas propre à vis ta
vie tu as découvert voilà vita à les
jurés que nous ne sommes pas complices
vous le jurer semaine avait lieu chez à
surmonter en enfer d'accord vous croyez
pas l'enfer j'imagine finissez votre
promotion chez patrick sébastien
on a la qualité on est bon très bien il
ya une carte sur ce carnet une et une
seule
j'aimerais vous pensiez une carte et
l'a4 laquelle vous pensez vita c'est le
48 heures dit à quelqu'un pensez vous
une carte d'un geste qu'avez vous dit à
4 c'est l'un des plus gros l'as de
carreau si ici écrit ta carte juste là
sur la première page
ça tue ça déchire et bien écoute sur
cette première page j écris ta carte
n'ont rien de bien parce que j'ai écrite
à cap mais ta carte je vais écrire est
dans la pince et tu vas remarquera que
ici depuis le début la mienne parce
qu'il ya une pince il ya une carte
depuis le début l'as de carreau tu as
choisi en retire je prends la carte
hélas non une carte qu'une et une seule
la la sur cette première page de quand
même il ya maintenant le dessin d'une
d'une carte pense à une autre car pana
c'est trop facile une autre carpita on
n'est pas que je regarde dans les yeux
tu penses à la carte
ouais c'est très flatteur mais pense à
la carte ces bombes paveway que la carte
que vous pensez maintenant dix des
treize le dise de 13 est juste là il ya
écrit 10 de trait
suisse la nôtre le truc de malade
on va aller plus loin on va aller plus
loin parce que j'aimerais que vous
imaginez que votre carte soit là juste
là dans l'espace j'aimerais que comme
tout à l'heure dans la pince vous savez
elle était plié j'aimerais que vous la
plier en quatre mentalement d'accord et
la regarder dans ma pince qui est là la
carte c'était quoi là car je me disais
c'est le diable si j'ouvre la carte ici
on voit que une carte territoire
excellent en tournée dans toute la botte
magique de l'est
merci le thriller fear est avec nous
[Musique]